squid game is our latest television
obsession and we bet it's yours too the
heart-pounding korean drama has taken
netflix by storm ranking as the number
one most watched show in a staggering 90
different countries as reported by
forbes spoilers ahead for season one the
nine episode series follows song gee hun
a down on his luck man who finds his
entire life change when a stranger
offers him the chance to join a game for
an unthinkable sum of money however what
he thinks might just be a series of
wacky games turns out to be a horrifying
experience if you lose you're not just
eliminated from the game you are killed
as the season progresses we discover the
entire game is a plot launched by the
uber rich who gain pleasure from
watching and betting on the participants
as they fight to the death by the end of
the season gihon manages to win the
contest and the jaw-dropping prize sum
of approximately 38.4 million us dollars
however taking part in such a brutal
experience changes him and the series
ends with what appears to be gihen
racing off to use his newfound means to
take down the entire operation like any
good suspenseful show though the final
episode leaves us with some questions
and eager for a second season fans have
taken to social media to speculate what
might become of gihon's future and one
theory provides a very intriguing
concept will gihen return to the game as
a god over on tick tock user chloe x
provides a very interesting theory about
gihon's next moves in the last episode
after discovering fellow player o il nam
was not his friend but in fact the
mastermind behind the entire game gihon
finally opts to use his prize money
after leaving it untouched for a full
year like many people entering a new
stage of life gihon decides to mark the
occasion with a haircut swapping his
shaggy dark lux for a short bright red
style throughout all of squid game gehen
on the other 455 contestants wore green
tracksuits while the soldiers monitoring
them were outfitted in red chloe x
suggests that gehen's new red hair might
mean he'll be returning to the island to
join the ranks of the soldiers perhaps
in an undercover operation similar to
that of police officer huang joon-ho of
course a job opportunity might be
difficult considering that gihon ends
his call with the front man promising
that he can't forgive him for what the
organization's done regardless it's
definitely an intriguing theory it will
not only give the second season a fresh
approach but also provide a natural way
to explore the behind the scenes aspects
of the game itself in more detail while
season 1 focused on the lives of the
contestants and even gave us a peek at
the vips who came to watch the games
play out the guards mostly stayed
figuratively and literally behind their
masks juno offered an intriguing glimpse
of their daily lives while undercover
but he had bigger things on his mind
than exploring the rules and regulations
of the masked henchmen having gihen
joining their ranks could provide ample
opportunity for a closer look at the
people who make the games possible and
even though it's merely a fan's
hypothesis as of now some recent
comments from squid game writer director
huang dong huk leave the door open for
it to go from theory to reality now it's
important to keep in mind that squid
game season 2 has yet to be confirmed
and dunk has kept his cards relatively
close to his chest when it comes to
speaking about what could possibly
happen in a second outing of the show
but during an interview with radio times
he did talk about the creative approach
he might take to season two
hypothetically speaking of course dunk
revealed that fan reaction could play a
big role in the development of a
potential next installment of squid game
specifically around what he describes as
huge expectations for season two the
director went on to explain it's not
that i haven't thought about season two
at all and they also do have a rough
framework for it but i keep asking
myself whether i can make it better than
season one i do not want people to get
disappointed over the new season
i just have to say that i'm a difficult
man to please
i hope you won't disappoint me
meeting fine expectations especially for
a series as popular as squid game it's a
daunting task of course we won't know
anything concrete about what season 2 of
squid game will be like until it
hopefully hits our screens in the
meantime we'll be patiently waiting and
theorizing and never looking at
children's playground games the same
ever again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one